.
Dans la région de Montréal,
une dizaine d'écoles secondaires
à des degrés divers.
- C'est le fun de sortir,
ça nous permet de s'oxygener
le cerveau.
- Dès qu'on est bien habil
vraiment froid.
- On apprend mieux
c'est... on est au plein milieu
de la nature.
- Je vous parlais du territ du e
de la Gaspésie...
- Les vertus de l'apprentissage
en plein air sont prouvées.
Mais entre la théorie
et la prvert impose
toute une logistique,
particul au secondaire.
CÉDRIC COUTURE, éduc. physique,
École Mgr-A.-M.-Parent
- C'est  approuver approuver ap,
par les parents.
BOUCHARD, enseignante
sciences, École Mgr-A.-M.-Parent
- Il faut que mes horaires
quence. Donc,
ça prend de l'ajustement.
vous dirais que,
le plus difficile cette année,
c'est... c'est le manque de
- Il y a une dizaine de profils
Plein Air dans les écoles
secondaires du Grand Montréal.
Celui de l'école Monseigneur-'il
combine sciences et plein Air.
va tellement ensemble.
Et il y a tellement de choses
de-Boucherville, la théorie
peut menacer l'équilibre
ture.
L'invasion de phragmites
qui prennent la place
- Ils ont deux manières
produire.
Ça fait qu'ils sont... c'est
des plantes envahissantes.
de glace sur le fleuve.- Pendan,
je traversais en ski
sur les îles ici,
complètement gelé.- C'est donc s
qu'une sortie de ski de fond.
Et, qui a commen
- Je peuTout le Tout le Tout le.
Est-ce que vous comprenez bien
le principe?
- En quelques années,
des périodes de sciences
et d'éducation phy
est devenu très populaire.
- J'aime
apprendre les points techniques
des sporfait que lfait que lfai,
on est en train d'apprendre
comment
puis c'est très important.
- À l'école de La Dauversière,
à Montréal, c'est la nécessité
d'un profil Plein Air
pour lesde premiède premiède pre
et deuxième secondaire
en septembre dernier.
coord. Plein Air, La Dauversière
- Dès rs jours
de l'année, je leur ai dit :
"On n'a pas le choix,
On va sortir à tous les cours,
ps, mauvais temps."
- La direction de cette école,
qui manqgnant en éducation
physique spécialisé
en plein air urbain.
- On va juste rappeler
- Même à -10 °C, les jeunes
occupent le parc public situé
juste en face de l'école.
- On a à faire un camp, bien,
On doit faire un sofa de neige.
- Est-ce que vous avez testé
les hamacs?
- Oui.
ce profil Plein Air, qui
intéress enseignants.
ÉLAINE LEITH,  École secondaire
La Dauversière et Évangeline
de prendre le prétexte
air et de l'amener
au service de l'apprentissage
des autres matières.êmeêmeêmeême
dans plus d'écoles qu'on
le pense, parce que les élèves
au grand air, de mieux respirer
pendant qu'on travaille.
Ça aide, la réflexion
est meilleure.
là pour ça. Donc, là... Ouf!
Enfin, on peut s
- Vivement un retour
à la normale pour que les élèves
reprendre leurs sorties
scientifiques, habttttttttt
une dizaine par année.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,